you are very into rap yes and and you
are about to drop I never get to say
that you're gonna drop your first album
yes yes yes me Myles William we have the
stakeholder moguls got a team he's
working with like Drake little Wayne who
a gazelle UTI true life he did freedom
he was he did a freedom on Beyonce's
album like this guy is like and he's
we're both we're both from the same age
so you know my raps you know I rap I
Spit I got boss people you know how long
you been working on this oh I've been
working on this project for like at
least like a year or some change but I
have been rapping since I was 13 I
started rapping before I did comedy so a
lot of people don't know that but what
do you rap about when you're 13 and you
haven't you haven't experienced life yet
I'm sure it's like what do you rap about
well you know I was always overweight
and nobody liked me so it was just about
that being fat it was like you loved
that so some really some really really
tough rap about being a heavy who's a
yeah yo yo I'm in the pool not taking my
shirt off why cuz I want you to see my
tits
[Applause]
it has changed it definitely does change
it is not the same anyone can see it now
like now rapid never wrap them like
but now they'll do that
I don't do that I don't do that what I
do now I'm basically like the male
Taylor Swift that's what I am mean I'm
saying really everybody who was mean to
me when I was younger like I just
wrapped and I just rip I'm like yo what
up Sarah from Petsmart yeah I was your
friend
oh hey Jamal said I wore the funny but
guess what I'm getting money and you not
did you work at Chipotle Beach I gotta
have this album
dude what's it called it is gonna be
called the silver screen I'm really
looking forward to it yeah I'm really
important to it wait famous is really
funny show it's great congratulations
thank you Bri like famous airs Sundays
at 10:30 p.m. on Showtime Jay you're
hilarious
Hey
[Applause]
you